bien une ou deux personnes qu'on a plus
envie de voir écoute on a dit de pas la
faire Cyril Hanouna
oh en fait je mettais une tarte pour ça
maintenant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
situation de handicap il est la victime
de ses camarades depuis plusieurs années
de sa mère et de son avocat ce soir dans
TPMP merci la mélodie merci d'être là
vraiment merci à vous de vouloir on
espère que ça va faire bouger les choses
Rudy à un handicap c'est quel est son
handicaps
avec impulsivité et en plus il est un
pied plat valgus très prononcé donc il a
une démarche un peu particulière en fait
ça a commencé le jeudi et donc un groupe
de jeunes voulaient la cigarette
électronique de mon fils et ils l'ont
poussé contre un homme Brabus et mon
père qui passait vraiment par hasard qui
a un ancien policier le Dias on a mis oh
là là il y a un jeune qui va se faire
lyncher j'y vais enfin je vais arrêter
ça les boxs
les jeunes sont partis et puis il y
avait dit bon monde dans la voiture je
te ramène donc moi il m'en parle donc
bon je me suis dit une histoire parmi
tant d'autres et le lundi c'est la CPE
m'appelle en disant votre fils vient
d'être prêt à partir par plusieurs
jeunes mais sans dehors du lycée donc ça
nous regarde pas alors là j'ai dit j'en
avais vraiment marre et je voulais que
j'allais porter plainte quand
l'agression est vieux qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé il aurait dit venu rentrer à
la maison après et vous a raconté
à l'hôpital parce que moi j'ai les
autres enfants à la maison donc j'ai pas
pu y aller
5 d'accord
il veut pas sortir tout seul je suis
obligée de l'accompagner quand j'étais à
l'hôpital aux UMJ pour faire ses
juridicités il est sorti et puis rentré
par peur dans la voiture en me disant
maman ils sont là ils sont là ils sont
là mais c'est pas possible ils sont en
garde à vue
facilement voilà
localisable ou si on peut facilement les
tout le monde n'a pas été interpellé le
manque de
retourner à l'école il veut pas y
retourner il veut pas y retourner il
veut pas retourner dans cette école pour
le comprendre ah mais je le comprends
puisqu'il y a quand même deux personnes
qui se sont qui sont pas interpellés
donc on lui demande de retourner à
l'école de les voir et en plus il est
quand même la risée de son lycée faut
savoir que les vidéos ils ont tourné ils
se sont moqués de lui ils se sont en
disant qu'ils étaient même pas capable
de se défendre qu'il était même pas
capable de défendre contre une fille ce
qui est la deuxième agression le même
jour
donc il y a une première agression par
combien de personnes ils étaient 4 5 il
y a une deuxième agression c'est ça le
même jour le même jour deux heures après
c'est très dur c'est très dur parce que
j'aurais préféré être à sa place en fait
plus que lui il faut savoir que moi j'ai
une autre fille qui a la même pathologie
que mon fils et elle m'a posé la
question de maman on fera ça plus tard
il y a 8 ans
j'ai une autre fille qui est au collège
on l'a clairement l'embêté on l'a
menacée en lui disant tu vas finir comme
ton frère j'ai dû enfin j'ai dû tout de
suite mettre Léo là tout de suite aller
recevait des messages en disant que
voilà tu finiras comme ton frère que
c'était une [ __ ] qui était même pas
capable de se défendre donc elle a
craqué elle a pleuré elle a 12 ans
effectivement on va dénoncer des faits
qu'est-ce qui se passe derrière les
parents habituellement on ne couvre pas
les enfants ou en tout cas on va les
protéger et là on va les couvrir on
venant menacer ma cliente en disant
c'est pas normal il faut retirer votre
plainte parce que sinon vous allez voir
ce que vous allez voir il y a une plante
qui a été déposé contre une mère de
famille non si c'est vrai il y a dit
qu'il vous a menacé qui vous a dit sinon
vous allez voir ce que vous allez voir
alors elles ont commencé par s'excuser
donc j'ai trouvé ça super gentil de leur
part je leur ai dit et ils m'ont dit
mais tout ça c'est de la faute de Rudy
tout ça c'est de sa faute
pourquoi parce que c'est eux qui les
cherche et qu'il les traite et se
protège en disant que il a eu des propos
racistes
voilà ils ne sont pas confirmés par le
procureur pour le moment nous passons
pas confirmés par le procureur
exactement voilà absolument absolument
et mon mari et les deux couleurs et mes
enfants sont métisses donc c'est pas
possible
et c'est vrai que là c'est la folie je
voudrais juste montrer cette situation
regardez les grosses tensions on assiste
à des bagarres dans les stations-service
partout tous les jours regardez
[Musique]
combien va durer la situation combien de
temps va durer la situation bah ça je
crois qu'il faudrait que vous invitiez
Monsieur Patrick pouyanet qui est le PDG
de Total à votre émission pour le savoir
parce que nous c'est cette situation est
dure depuis le mois de mars d'accord
aujourd'hui quand total affirme que les
grévistes gagnent environ 5000 euros par
mois avec les primes vous réagissez
comment et ben c'est totalement faux je
ne sais pas comment ils font leur calcul
j'ai ici dans mon portable une feuille
de paye d'un opérateur un opérateur de
raffinerie qui a 20 ans d'ancienneté qui
est donc est consoliste il gagne environ
2900 euros par mois d'accord et est-ce
que vous pouvez pas
négocier sans continuer la grève c'est
un petit peu ce qui semble bloqué en
fait
100%
c'est à Lyon en fait c'est une
raffinerie qui est dans la banlieue
Feyzin voilà c'est ça exactement et en
fait on bloque pas on les camions
rentrent ils peuvent rentrer mais il y a
personne dedans c'est tout après moi je
suis venu aussi pour expliquer qu'on
n'est pas juste sur les salaires à la
base d'accord c'est vrai que tout le
monde nous salit en fait c'est une
question de pour l'opinion publique en
fait c'est un peu de ça mais nous on est
surtout sur l'investissement dans nos
raffineries et sur l'embauche parce que
nous raffineries elles sont pourries
un accident il y a de la population
autour voilà et malheureusement et c'est
vrai qu'on le sait très bien moi j'ai
une famille aussi je fais la queue comme
vous aussi j'en suis conscient ma mère
mon père ma femme c'est pareil et j'en
suis conscient et j'en suis le premier
euh je veux dire pareil je suis prêt en
otage aussi comme vous mais
malheureusement on fait de l'essence
j'aurais fait du pain il y aurait pas de
pain mais ça va peut-être touche un peu
moins de monde et on fait grève pour
tout ce qui se passe c'est à dire pour
tout ce qui est augmentation de salaire
parce qu'aujourd'hui l'inflation et ben
elle est là quand on a 10% oui notre
première demande à 10%
autour de jade l'année dernière qu'on a
rien eu hein je vous rappelle qu'on
aurait eu il faut rappeler aussi qu'il
faut des milliards de bénéfices je vais
pas rentrer dans le débat est-ce que
votre combat est légitime ou pas je vais
être honnête à titre purement personnel
comme au titre de tous les Automobil
vous nous forcez à prendre des opinions
qu'on n'a pas à prendre exact ça vous
regarde vous dans un conflit qui vous
oppose à vos directions le problème
c'est que sur la route il y a 40
millions d'otages je vais vous donner
juste une idée reprenez le boulot mais
marquez le fait que vous avez besoin
d'investissement sur votre lieu de
travail parce que là vous allez toucher
les gens vous les aurez les médias ils
seront là le message va passer faites
des banderoles marquez vos différences
mais retourner bosser pour montrer que
vous êtes avec nous et pas contre nous
c'est vrai c'est bien
franchement c'est la direction totale et
le gouvernement ils auraient pu se
réveiller avant et pas laisser pourrir
ce truc
notre hiérarchie la direction à Feyzin
de la raffinerie passe devant nous on
leur demande mais depuis 15 jours
pratiquement et il y a rien il y a rien
il nous ignore ce soir là mais quand
même un petit peu de monde derrière
l'écran qu'est-ce qui vous empêche ce
soir de répondre à ma question en disant
mais ok c'est une bonne idée ce que vous
dites monsieur chasserez 40 millions
d'automobilistes ok on va le faire on va
mettre un brassard un truc on va en
parler à nos directions puis on va
retourner au boulot pour débloquer la
situation pourquoi vous faites pas ça
serait moi mais moi
mais si vous l'avez ce pouvoir tout le
monde a du pouvoir
c'est pas moi je parle pas pour tout le
monde
si la Réunion est concluante vous pouvez
reprendre le travail quand demain matin
tous les matins avant de reprendre le
boulot on se réunit tous qu'est-ce qu'on
en pense déjà il y a la direction qui
vient aussi
vous allez demain matin vous allez
savoir si voilà ça vous convient ou pas
donc demain ça peut bouger exactement
un grand prix de formule 4 opposant 22
streamers et youtubers c'est la première
fois avec une chaîne française atteint
un pido d'audience supérieur au milieu
de téléspectateurs et Squeezie a même
dit qu'il faisait plus que beaucoup
d'émissions de télé
la streamer est youtubeur ce sera
rassembler au circuit Bugatti du Mans
pour participer à une course de formule
4 diffuseur live sur twitch tu ferais
pour vous
l'événement organisé par le youtuber
Squeezie a réuni 40 000 spectateurs et
plus d'un million de viewers sur twitch
à record français et la cinquième plus
grosse audience mondiale Squeezie
qu'est-ce qu'on est partout le public
Bugatti j'ai félicité Squeezie et c'est
vrai que ça m'a mes équipes m'ont dit
mais tu es fou tu n'aurais pas dû le
féliciter parce qu'il t'avait mis un tag
il y a quelques années vous n'êtes pas
rancunier vous êtes
non plus je l'aime bien Squeezie je sais
pas j'aimais bien et il paraît qu'il m'a
mis un tag dans l'émission c'était en
salut ou celle que vous aimeriez ne plus
voir en 2017 je n'attends pas 2017 pour
ne plus voir les gens que je peux voir
quand même quand même ouais il y avait
une ou deux personnes qu'on a plus envie
de voir écoute on a dit pas la faire
Cyril Hanouna
2017 allez c'est parti le clash alors
alors
[Musique]
j'espère voilà s'il veut m'appeler donc
c'était dans le sang
et là tu l'as dit à mon avis
voilà exactement bravo machines
après c'est vrai qu'à l'époque en 2017
je mettais une tarte pour ça maintenant
je me sens bien sûr pour le changement
quand même vous avez changé de manière
change pour rester vous aviez oublié qui
vous avez taquet il y a un nom
certainement oui aussi
c'est pas une nature tu es devenu
amnésique
[Applaudissements]
des excès de vitesse des feux rouges
grillés mais aussi des tirs blancs avec
un pistolet d'alarme qui ont semé la
terreur dans la ville passe à toutes ces
incivilités le maire de la commune a
décidé d'annuler leur mariage à quelques
minutes de la cérémonie vous êtes donc
Thibault Philips le maire de la ville
d'irkish Graffenstaden
Monsieur le Maire qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé samedi alors en fait samedi j'ai
revenais tranquillement de course au
centre-ville de Strasbourg vous avez
pris de l'essence
de voir la voiture électrique
par mes réseaux sociaux par message en
me disant bah il y a un cortège qui qui
est en train de s'élancer dans la ville
et des voitures qui bloquent carrément
des rues pour les privatiser faire des
excès de vitesse avec des berlines
louées en Allemagne et ne respectait
aucune règle du code de la route surtout
des coups de feu et on n'était pas on ne
savait pas à ce moment-là le type de
coup de société puisqu'on savait pas si
c'était un pistolet d'alarme ou pas les
habitants ils ont ils ont flippé quoi
ils ont tous eu vraiment très très peur
et c'est pour ça que moi je me suis
rendu immédiatement à la mairie puisque
c'est un de mes adjoints qui devait
célébrer le mariage c'est pas vous qui
devez céder et donc je suis allé tout de
suite à la mairie et quand je suis
arrivé à la mairie j'ai assisté à la
scène où la brigade antique criminalité
interpellé les les trois les trois
personnes à l'intérieur du véhicule et
notamment le porteur de l'arme puisqu'on
ne savait pas à ce moment-là quel type
d'arme ça pouvait être prends contact
avec l'officier de police qui était à ce
moment-là en charge de cette de cette
interpellation et je lui dis bah écoutez
moi je prends la décision d'annuler le
mariage il faut que j'aille voir mon
adjoint votre adjoint vous lui avez dit
quoi on fait pas le mariage en fait j'ai
dû j'ai dû faire venir mon adjoint on a
été mis dans une pièce de la mairie
protégée par la police pour pouvoir
discuter parce que la police avait peur
justement qu'à un moment ça puisse
s'envenimer et la police nous a dit ben
ok pour l'annulation mais il faut
patienter on va appeler des renforts
pour pouvoir évacuer la mairie parce que
on veut pas que ça parte ça parte dans
n'importe quoi mettre Mohamed Achour
vous êtes donc l'avocat du couple de
mariée
vous est-ce que vous pouvez nous
raconter votre version des faits
en fait elle diffère un petit peu de
celle de Monsieur le Maire
globalement en fait ce qui s'est passé
donc ça a été raconté donc on a eu en
fait ce cortège là ce qu'il faut savoir
en fait c'est que la mariée habite sur
la commune de Illkirch mais pour se
rendre à la mairie on a à peu près pour
aller entre 3 et 5 minutes je dis pas il
y a forcément eu des infractions au code
de la route ça arrive régulièrement en
fait dans ce type dans ce type dans ce
type de cortège mais il y avait pas en
fait il y avait pas de rodéo au sens où
comme ce qu'on avait vu tout à l'heure
en fait on a des dérapages ça tourne de
partout vous nous dites c'est entre 3 et
5 minutes tu peux pas une patrouille de
police de la BAC qui était déjà présente
sur Illkirch et qui a été alerté qui
avait en fait un souci un souci avec
avec ce cortège et notamment en fait les
tirs par arme à feu ils interpellent les
occupants du véhicule sur le parvis sur
le parvis de la mairie donc ils sont
arrêtés sur le parvis de la mairie déjà
le premier correctif à apporter il y a
pas eu trois personnes d'interpeller
mais une seule le conducteur le
conducteur c'est le frère le frère du
marié voilà qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait
les mariés est-ce qu'une faute
individuelle peut-être collective ça
n'existe pas quand vous voyez un cortège
complet avec justement le cortège du
mariage qui fait plein d'infractions au
code de la route moi j'estime que certes
il y a le tireur qui a son arme et tout
ça pour le pour lequel vous êtes
intervenus au tribunal mais ça n'enlève
pas qu'il y a eu toutes ces infractions
au code de la route il y a eu quand même
des
je ne comprends pas je trouve que vous
avez été bien trop loin d'ailleurs vous
pouvez être attaqué au tribunal c'est
presque vous avez presque contrepassé
vos fonctions non j'ai pas autre passé
mes fonctions j'ai exercé mon pouvoir de
police et comme j'estime qu'à partir du
moment où je ne peux pas garantir qu'en
sortant de la mairie ensuite il y a pas
de trouble à l'ordre public la décision
que j'ai prise elle a été prise en
discutant aussi avec les policiers qui
m'ont tout à fait soutenu et avec les
différentes institutions qui m'ont
soutenu parce que je demande très
respectueusement Homère est-ce que le
fait que ces gens étaient de confession
musulmane influer sur votre décision
non mais excusez-moi j'ai posé une
question
de poser une question maintenant si on a
pu le droit de poser des questions
moi j'estime que c'est pas pourquoi j'ai
une pose cette question c'est pas des
propos corrects je trouve ça vraiment
dommageable parce que au quotidien je
célèbre des mariages avec peu importe
qui sont les habitants de ma ville ce
sont les habitants de ma ville mais
après en tant que j'ai un devoir de
protéger ma population et là j'estime
avoir protégé ma population parce que il
y avait des débordeurs
ont ressenti ça comme des débordements
voilà
sont les petites combines ce qu'ils ont
appelé les petites combines des forains
pour gagner de l'argent notamment au jeu
de la pince vous avez déjà tous voilà
tous le jeu de lapin regarde avec cette
manette il faut diriger le crochet pour
attraper des peluches et autres cadeaux
au niveau en fait de la technique c'est
à dire que en fait en travaillant sur
sur les réglages je peux dire à la
machine voilà tu gagnes tout le temps
par contre je peux lui dire voilà tu
gagnes à 1 sur 1 tu gagnes un sur deux
je dis à gagne un sur trois ou un sur 25
vous aurez beau vous acharner rien n'y
changera la force de la pince est réglée
à l'avance c'est comme au casino arrêtez
tu mets 1 euro au casino tu gagnes pas
un million d'euros je veux dire c'est
ils sont dans un monde où les gens de
pouvoir croire ça réglementer
95% c'est la loi tu vas pas pour gagner
de l'argent
Mathieu ce qu'on est en train de dire
c'est que au casino aussi ils savent un
peu qui va gagner parce que c'est un
moment la machine va donner oui moi j'ai
pas du tout aimé ce reportage qui était
clairement à charge en fait on fait
passer les forains pour des arnaqueurs
pour des gens malhonnêtes qui respectent
aucune loi qui emploie des enfants enfin
la manière dont tout était raconté
c'était horrible d'abord ils sont très
riches d'abord c'est pour créer l'envie
créé avec un reportage on peut tordre la
réalité dans un sens ou dans un autre
moi j'ai vu des gens hyper soudés qui
roulent pas forcément sur l'or et pardon
mais le truc de lapin c'est nul mais il
faut penser il t'attendais ça un
commerce il y a l'emplacement il y a
l'électricité le mec qui vient de pas
gratuit il faut comprendre ça tu payes
tout oui mais c'est les gens jouent ils
ont envie de gagner tu vas Disney un
paquet de chips à 4,50 € de quoi tu me
parles et comme ça le paquet de chips en
vérité quand tu vas la fête foraine tu
dis voilà je vais dépenser ton je vais
faire telle telle attraction mais tu vas
pour le kit si tu vas à la fête foraine
pour te dire je vais devenir
millionnaire je vais gagner toutes les
pièces qui vont tomber ou je vais gagner
un iPhone ou une bonne voiture non je
suis désolé voilà c'était donc en fait
c'est des trucs ça juste pour [ __ ] les
gens dans la merde voilà je pense que
les gens dans la merde moi je suis
d'accord avec vous le stigmatiser les
gens du voyage mais ensuite là où je ne
suis plus d'accord c'est que mon cher
Enoch c'est quand même une gigantesque
arnaque les carabines sont truquées on
apprend que quand on tire la carabine
c'est truqué la grue la machine à pince
c'est fait pour que les gens perdent
donc une autre qu'ils ont quand même une
organisation pour arnaquer les gens
c'est pas c'est pas nouveau mais c'est
pas nouveau ça veut dire que le mot est
gros là là tu prends un exemple c'est
comme si vous savez quoi c'est comme
s'il y avait un mur blanc de 10 m est un
point noir et tu vois que le point noir
mon frère c'est parce que un il l'avait
on dirait que tout le monde vous savez
ce qui m'énerve c'est sur un fond de
racisme je vais vous expliquer non
attendez non mais c'est normal tu es
blonde yeux bleus mon frère tu sais pas
ce que c'est facile
d'être gitans mon frère au quotidien moi
je le sais mes enfants vont à l'école tu
sais ce que c'est d'être gitan
aujourd'hui il y a pas d'association
pour le protéger il y a rien
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a rien pour les
gitans aujourd'hui tu peux dire tu peux
mettre un panneau à l'entrée d'une ville
interdit aux gens du voyage fais-le pour
les Fages c'est le pour les sexuel c'est
le premier musulmans mais la ville elle
coule mais aujourd'hui en France tu peux
ça veut dire le Gitan tu peux tout dire
sur lui ça passe crème et moi un autre
jeu qui cartonne dans les fêtes foraines
c'est le tir à la carabine tout le monde
est persuadé qu'on peut faire craquer le
fil mais comme il a dit île il ne cède
jamais regarde pourquoi une majorité de
tireurs sur ruine sans pouvoir rompre la
fameuse ficelle avec vos talents à la
carabine ça vous arrive parfois d'aller
à la fête foraine au stand de tir pour
gagner des peluches au risque de trahir
un secret qui est bien gardé les
carabines sont déréglées et permet pas
au pont tirer de tirer correctement
voilà alors lui il est très bon dans son
domaine mais à mon avis il a pas fait
toutes les fêtes foraines le mec
attendez on le croit sur parole quoi on
a dit c'est vrai ils sont en fait parce
que c'est des forêts ils ne respectent
pas le fait que c'est un business mais
ils veulent quoi en fait qu'on gagne un
iPhone à chaque fois en dépensant 1 €
c'est pas compris il y a un mec qui
disait dans le reportage qui l'a payé
son manège 600000 euros il faut en
vendre des tickets pour rentabiliser le
service
gagne 1000 euros par mois donc faut
arrêter il était crédibilise parce que
c'est la même chose sur toutes les
entreprises toutes les entreprises
doivent faire du bénéfice de couper la
parole mais si tu leur dis si tu leur
dis les gitans sont gentils ça va bien
ma chaîne personne la regarde l'émission
mon frère alors je veux pas défendre
même si mais si tu leur
dis tout tu zappes sur les mariages
incroyable
les amis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]